[Music]
you
hello everyone my name is nari Seoul I'm
a pianist composer and today we're gonna
go over ways to sound like Erica city
first off we're going to establish a
melody let's infuse it with the church
mode in this case the Locrian mode next
add simple accompaniment that consists
of repetitive bass notes and chords
spaced above that similar to what may
loosely remind you of a waltz
accompaniment or stride piano
[Music]
now let's add another sound to these
cords to alternate with the previous one
there are several ways to look at this
particular case but one way to look at
it is alternating between Aeolian and
Aeolian with the flat 5
[Music]
in general choose scales and modes that
highlight semitones and augmented
seconds sati uses a lot of synthetic
scales and modified modes this can
become very complex but two easy ways to
access the sound is to focus on the
top-end of the harmonic minor scale
starting from the fourth degree and also
taking a minor triad and adding a
semitone below each note
[Music]
make sure to maintain a simple texture
when the hands are combined and avoid
filigree
[Music]
also add grace notes that complement the
resonance of a pitch
[Music]
favorite pairs of repeating notes but
not excessively
[Music]
use octaves to help the pitches ring
[Music]
include common Cadence's such as a play
go movement which adds a sweet touch
[Music]
and lastly maintain a spirit of a sort
of wandering whimsical nature and avoid
extreme temperaments
[Music]
you
[Music]
and now let's put it all together
[Music]
you
[Music]
so just some additional notes on satis
music oftentimes there's a lot of space
in between the notes allowing for the
pictures to resonate and also the
melodies are less rhetorical than
composers such as Chopin Beethoven and
Mozart in the sense that they are less
likely to develop and they're less
emotive so tea seems to focus more on
creating a sound world where of course
there are variations to the melodies in
short phrases but nothing to
developmental
what I love about satis melodies is that
they seem to hover really beautifully
over the harmonies that he creates
[Music]
obviously these points just cover the
surface layer of satis music I'm simply
a huge fan and these are just some
things that stick out to me when I
listen to his music
you
you
anyway thanks so much for watching
please subscribe if you haven't already
visit my site for sheet music and I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]